[Applause]
corey lanes
and is involved in a potential shooting
in the foot of mega staff
right yeah and um
they were in the car together whatever
the [ __ ] happens who cares
but it came out that tory was five three
yeah 120 pounds
maybe he was just putting the the gun by
his side just carrying it and it
happened to be right by where her foot
was
and then the gun went off he was too big
for him to handle yeah
maybe really he's just so short you know
i mean if you're this tall and you're
carrying some [ __ ] by your side that's
that'd make the stallion's feet
i mean probably scraping it mad times
but they were in the car
he screamed on the ground he was so
close to the crowd
but they were in the car that's what
they're saying
yeah that's crazy how you let that
little [ __ ] drive that's my
question
yo let's be let's have a real talk about
this
you've heard tory songs great music sure
i like the music yeah i think he's like
really talented at making like
pop r b rap okay yep
is there a certain height requirement
for arrogance
like you're allowed to be yeah like i'm
gonna take your [ __ ]
how can you take that [ __ ] shopping how
are you gonna take her anywhere
you're not gonna piggyback her she could
push you in a stroller she's gonna take
you
but like five three 120 all that
arrogance on the track come on bro
that's mad little yo napoleon complex
man so you think it's
all all the short ones are the most
arrogant little wayne
low bow wow how tall lil wayne he's
about five three five four get the [ __ ]
out of these guys are shorter than kevin
hart
you know he's five four yeah but you
have a solo weight in low waiting
five oh five five yeah [ __ ]
kendrick lamar's five six
uzi verts 5'4 really
so i think a little duval pointed some
[ __ ] out to me that i think is really
interesting yo little [ __ ] be
he should be little tory lanez little
tory
little bow wow little wayne little josie
vert gay
little so little uh little duval said
this to me he goes
fat dudes make the best love songs i go
what are you talking about he goes
because they they write the best love
songs because
they write about women in a way that
dudes that get [ __ ]
would never think about right i miss
your smell
i mean i don't you mean the world to me
i'm actually saying [ __ ] you're supposed
to say to your girl but like
they they they speak and they think and
fantasize about women right
in a way that the guy who gets laid
doesn't usually fantasize right
right and i wonder if short dudes
make the best brag rappers
because they fantasize about being the
man
in a way that a guy who's jay-z's height
doesn't right you know what i mean or
like i'm trying to think of another like
uh
tall rapper like the game or some [ __ ]
like who would like a big rapper that
probably got laid or got some [ __ ] yeah
waka flog is huge i mean
like six six yeah so it's just like if
you're tiny
you're how would i be if i was the man
how would i act if i was a man how would
girls treat me if i was a man what could
i do possibly
if i was the man and you got to put on
that persona a lot of times just so
people take you seriously and you become
really good at acting
yeah and maybe that's why you have all
these actors
the tom cruises of the world yeah five
five or whatever it is yo scientology
don't seem that bad now that pedophiles
is out here right
what remember good point you remember
how crazy
scientology was like oh yeah they got
your secrets and
you might be closet gay you know protect
it and we were like oh my god that's so
horrible
and then we found out there's like a
legit [ __ ] pedophile ring out there
you know what i mean yeah clear it up
yeah clear it up
skin is about as unclear as the kids
that you're having sex
but for real maybe that's why they're so
good at acting
like superstars are so good at acting
like um
what is it the action hero the what is
that called
the megastar gonis or whatever yeah
protagonist but like
the hero i don't know there's another
another name for it like the leading man
yeah the leading man like maybe they're
so good at playing that role because
they've been pretending to be that and
like
wondering what it would be like to be
that role their entire lives
you know what i'm saying you know how
like uh drag queens make the sassiest
girls
yeah they're dreaming about what it
would be like to be a girl
oh i'd click my teeth and i'd snap my
fingers all the [ __ ] time like
they'd figure out the best girl makeup
they know how to do like all these um
what is it called the girls do um
contours
apparently that's all from drag makeup
yeah so they stole it from dudes trying
to be the best girls
right i wonder if that's what it is it's
like all these actors though like the
star hollywood actors like the studs
they're all just like theater kids
they're just nerds like uh the dude that
plays ron swanson david offerman nick
offerman yeah like he's supposed to be
like the man's man
his guy he was like some thespian dude
like he has a quote about where he's
like yeah people think i'm supposed to
be like some tough meat-eating guy like
i've been vegetarian for like 20 years
like he's like i'm none of that like zac
efron went to like some like
arts like drama conservatory like that's
hilarious
which not to say like they're piece of
[ __ ] but like
not they'll make you piece of [ __ ] but
it is interesting they're just not that
like
i don't know the masculine persona that
they might
present all the time i mean i get that
from an actor to be honest and i never
thought zac efron was mad masculine
doing high school musical
but like yeah i think it's just you also
need people to take you seriously so if
you're a drag queen
you need to be seen as a woman as much
as you can so beyond even just
fantasizing i gotta learn everything i
can about
how to look like a woman act like a
woman like i need to really be a woman
for people that take me seriously as a
woman and i got this insecurities they
won't so i overcompensate little dudes
always worry about getting picked on
so they always act like they're willing
to fight i'm the exception i'm trying to
fight nobody
but like you know hey [ __ ] that i gotta
get taken seriously as a man so i'm
gonna overcompensate with
is overcompensation the key to success
yes that's a good question i really
wonder
because if you go like i think the
overcompensation and then also there's
something where
most successful people just don't see
anything
wrong with the way they navigate life
like they don't second-guess themselves
it's like it's like no i'm i focus like
a stallion wearing that [ __ ] thing
yeah yeah yeah it's like i see that
characteristics
with a lot of you know is that
overcompensation
no i think it's the combination of those
two things so if you have like
maybe not necessarily the
overcompensation it could also just be
like a
crazy amount of confidence and then also
what
you don't have that thing that most
people have that makes them doubt
themselves
right i really wonder if what we call
perfectionism or whatever it is is a
version of overcompensation
like i wonder if if when we're cutting
a clip and we're like shaving every word
down and like changing oh this line
needs this and this nine needs that
instead of like i want it to be perfect
it's i don't want
people to think a way about me that i
think about myself
yeah i talked to my cousin once who's
this does that make sense yeah i talked
to my cousin a psychiatrist
yeah and i was like yeah yeah and i was
like so is art
the [ __ ] girl you dying
she died let her die let her know what
it's all good go on
is our entire personality just defense
mechanisms and he's like yeah basically
you navigate the world because you don't
want to get made fun of these things
you're insecure about
and that forms pretty much your entire
personality
so my god dude i think this dog is legit
dying pass me the dog else what if the
dog dies in the pocket
i mean that'd be kind of fire you know
what i mean
let me see this thing yeah i wonder i
really wonder man
i wonder if that's the key i wonder if
it's hard to be successful at all if
you're not
if you're not carrying some sort of
insecurity
because if you felt completely satisfied
with everything about yourself
we wouldn't do this you wouldn't put out
work for people to judge nope
like all these like that's why you got
to be a little skeptical of all these
like
instagram gurus you know [ __ ]
like telling you what to do and
get up in the morning do 20 push-ups or
take the day on or whatever it's like
if you felt 100 satisfied in you
you wouldn't be doing this and you know
why they might be the most insecure
because they're doing something that
everybody's going to validate
everybody's going to double tap that
heart everybody's going to leave a
positive comment
i'm sure there's insecurity that drives
us doing [ __ ] that people aren't gonna
like also
but like i feel like it almost takes
more insecurity to say hey look here's a
really positive thing everybody
like this for me everybody double tap
because you're not getting any negative
criticism nobody's like yo [ __ ] you yeah
piece of [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah
it is interesting but or maybe those
people are also
the most empty and they found a way to
fill the emptiness with some like
positive [ __ ] in their life
like maybe that tony robbins guy maybe i
think he did come from like a really
kind of [ __ ] up family
for sure i think i think he had like
some weird relationship with his mom and
[ __ ] like
it was [ __ ] up stuff yeah and then he
found
happiness through all these exercises so
he's like yo let me share this with
these [ __ ] i get filled
because i get to make these people feel
good so selfishly it works for me
but oh [ __ ] it also works for these
people they you know save lives like he
probably legitive saved mad lives
so maybe that's all you need to do you
just need to like find a way
to like monetize harness your insecurity
yeah like harness your insecurity
and if there's an art or a skill or a
game or whatever it is that's associated
to that
insecurity right you can monetize that
and if you share it with the world and
then people benefit from it
then that's icing on the cake that's a
pretty good life
i think we just figured out life man now
yeah it's a good thing that meg is okay
she's healthy
can we come up with some scenarios where
he would have to shoot her in the foot
i mean she's 5 10. but i can't even
figure out you think he aimed at her
head yeah but it was so smooth at the
top of her foot
let's just say just him shooting her
period i can't figure out a scenario
where a guy would have to and they're
rumored to be dating as well so
there's no way and there's room son
those are the rumors man
how i'm just you've never seen what rise
of stallion a jockey
oh that's a good point so that's a
jockey height too fast
he was just trying to tame it yeah so
he's a jockey
yeah and he was trying to tame the
stallion yeah do you really think tory
could handle all that
no do you really you know how like when
there's a white dude that dates a black
girl
like black dudes would be like nah he
can't handle all that
yeah right yeah they used to say about
me
um uh but when you look at
her and tori you look at him like a
white guy
you're like there's no way he can handle
all that we didn't know how small he was
until now
and ain't he balding no he got his hair
back that guy got the worst jeans
bro he was pulled in five three dude
and 120. that's how you can make some
good music man that is
dude you ain't dating i was having my
free time in the studio yeah
might write some bars bro maybe they
tried to fight and she beat his ass
and then he was just like all right well
he just started fighting back yeah i
have to
i can't beat her in a fair fight when
you're when your boyfriend and i'm
asking to the girls that are watching
this podcast or listening to it if your
boyfriend is smaller than you
and he gets in a fight what do you do